hello I'm gonna stuff guy remember it so
you don't have to we all know how the
traditional movie formula is supposed to
go 3x structure a cast of characters
dealing with a conflict structured
around a beginning middle in it some do
it well some do it poorly but that's how
those people do it
that's probably why a lot of folks get
pissed off when they see a film like
Tree of Life
yeah there's characters and even some
conflicts but the story is backwards
frontwards sideways and sometimes just
abandoned all together for pretty
pictures and even a dinosaur yeah a
dinosaur is a story about family
dilemmas if that's even what this film
is about as you'd imagine people were
pretty split some say it was a
pretentious hand job to itself while
others say it's a beautiful
representation of life but that's not
the only movie people have felt that way
about in the past films like 2001 barton
fink and just about anything by david
lynch all have stories that seem to
abandon the 3s structure at some point
and just dive into the strange and
surreal there's no clear answers on what
they're about or what they're trying to
say it's all left open to the viewers
interpretation but the question is how
much should be left open to the viewers
interpretation I mean if I was just to
go Boonen nah
and told you that was open to
interpretation why would I be praised
why doesn't anybody who does anything
get hailed as a genius because they say
they're just leaving it open to
interpretation
well what's taken in baby steps we know
the 3x structure we stated before but
not every movie is going to have the
exact same one there has to be variation
obviously on character story and so on
if the film is going to be remembered or
worth anything that is except for
transformers and how that gets away with
it with that said even in the 3x
structure not everyone follows beginning
middle and end in that order
films like pulp fiction memento and
e-trial sunshine of the spotless mind
all have been praised for telling their
stories out of the traditional order but
they're still a flowing narrative and
characters you want to see go through a
satisfactory resolution but even that
sometimes can be played with even in big
blockbusters remember the ending to
Inception most of the movie is very
clear and straightforward I mean for a
nolan movie but the ending is purposely
left open for your interpretation yeah a
part of you is probably driven nuts by
that but at the same time you have to
admit there's probably a part of you
that appreciates the film for not
spoon-feeding everything to you the film
is about confusing dreams with reality
so most people caught on that the ending
should do exactly that blur the line
between what was real and what wasn't
most people agree was the perfect way to
end it Inception is obviously not the
first film to do this though lots of
elements in popular movies are left open
to the audience's imagination what's in
the briefcase in Pulp Fiction what did
Bill Murray say at the end of Lawson
translation lots of people are satisfied
that the movie challenges them to fill
in the blanks on their own they like
that a certain part can mean whatever
you want it to mean and thus make it
your own unique movie different from
anybody else's whatever you hear Bill
Murray whispered to Scarlett Johansson
is always going to be different from
what another person hears now if a
certain part of a movie can give you
that why not the majority of a film I
still have no idea what Mulholland Drive
is about but I do remember characters
and imagery dealing with dreams
nightmares the passion for success and
the anxiety of failure even the opening
as a point of view
a person waking up and going back to
sleep so my guess is rather than leaning
towards the details of the story they're
leaning towards the details of emotion
The Wizard of Oz is not a very logical
story there's lots of things we realized
when we grow up that don't make sense
about it but we follow it because the
emotions are so strong we fear for
Dorothy we're happy with her we're on
board with every emotion she's feeling
even the story doesn't always add up I
did a video a long time ago I won this
right to nitpick and I said that every
film is an illusion at some point
something's not going to make sense with
it just like any illusion in life films
like Mulholland Drive and Tree of Life
are trying to take it a step further
they don't bother with realistic or
flowing narrative their goal is to go
for pure emotion and emotion as we all
know is rarely logical films like this
are drenched in that these are movies
led by thoughts and feelings not rhyme
and reason the trying to take that
emotional abstractness in the ending of
Inception and stretch it out to be the
main focus but with that said when is it
done right and when is it done raw a lot
of people were pissed off at the ending
of TV shows like Sopranos and lost and
without giving away too much let's just
say they didn't answer a lot of
questions raised now why would that not
work here and yet work in something like
pulp fiction where we didn't get all the
answers either part of it is the two
shows are mostly about getting answers
Sopranos focused on battle plans and
strategies laws focused on constantly
figuring out a mystery while both had
abstract moments they clearly weren't
the focus of the show the characters
want to know what's going on that is
their goal so it also becomes our goal
therefore as the show gets closer and
closer to telling us what's going to
happen to them or what has been
happening to them we get pretty angry
when we're told we're not supposed to
know the answer in pulp fiction however
they know what's in the briefcase so we
don't need to in laws and translation
they know what Bill Murray said so we
don't need to in these shows they don't
know what happened so by God one of us
needs to know what happened either the
audience or the characters that's what
they were focusing on throughout the
majority of the series it's emotionally
unfulfilling because we just feel
frustration and that
than either of the show's purpose they
were supposed to be satisfying endings
that promised a lot but delivered little
there's an abstract film called Jerry
directed by Gus Van Sant which most
people despise and honestly I don't
entirely blame them
it's two guys walking in the desert and
that's it there's nothing special about
the desert it's not shot in a particular
way it's just two guys walking in a very
ordinary looking desert I won't ruin the
ending though really I don't think it
would be ruined even if I told you but
most of the movie is them walking in the
desert in total silence because of this
we can't get emotionally invested
because we don't know if they're even
emotionally invested they barely talk in
something like Waiting for Godot they
mostly speak nonsense but what they're
feeling is always in plain sight here
you can't grasp onto anything so very
few got into whatever the film's
intention was if a film is supposed to
make an emotional connection with you
there better be some goddamn emotion in
it but while some films can piss you off
and always leave you pissed off others
can actually get better the more you
think about it you know the phrase you
have to see it twice in order to fully
get it
well sometimes that is actually true I
take for example Charlie Kaufman Cindy
Cindy dude did Matt New York when I
first saw this film it pissed me off I
just couldn't understand any of it why
was the woman buying a house that was on
fire why is this guy's grown-up daughter
suddenly a little girl why do years pass
in literally a matter of seconds I saw
it as just a pretentious exercise in
trying to be artsy but then I gave it
another chance and I tried something a
little different I decided to start
asking questions rather than demanding
answers why would a woman buy a house on
fire as I thought about it reminded me
of some people I knew in my life who
would go into a bad situation even
though they knew it was going to be bad
I think a lot of us have known people
like that why was his grown-up daughter
a child sometimes and I thought about
the phrase that most fathers say to
their daughters where they'll always see
them as daddy's little girl well maybe
the movies indicating that's how he
literally still sees her and why did he
confuse just a few minutes ago for
actually a few years ago I think most of
us have
at a moment where you thought something
that happened recently actually happened
a long time ago and as you get older
time seems to fly by faster in the film
these are all very literal
interpretations but it's how he sees
things or at the very least how he's
experiencing it and suddenly a film I
hated was turning into a film I loved it
was like a world of events emotions and
thoughts unbound by time in fact by
taking those two elements away I
actually found I kind of understood than
more it's doing something totally
different and looking at cinema from a
completely new point of view
experimenting not feeling shamed by the
three-act structure and I was seeing
something in this movie as well as film
in general that I never really thought
about before
now does that mean you have to like
these films and you have to force others
to like them hell no you can hate them
all you want
maybe adventures gave you the most
emotional journey you ever had with a
film it's totally possible everyone is
gonna have their own reaction to a movie
but when you look at an abstract movie
and say it makes no sense it's no
different than when a person comes up to
you and says you just didn't get it yeah
don't you hate those the jerkles who
always say I don't get it so it must be
dumb or some thought that says you're
not smart enough to understand it both
those twats everyone finds meaning in
different places in different ways if
you don't find that with a film like
Tree of Life it's totally understandable
maybe you need something to connect more
to real life after all that's what
you're living isn't it
the facts of reality are so strange and
out there why would you want to
understand anything else this is hard
enough on the other hand someone else
can look at it and see the patterns of
life the passage of time how both
gigantic and insignificant man can truly
be but with that said maybe someone can
see the exact same qualities in a more
concrete film it's just different roads
to the same experience but the great
thing about film is that there is no one
book that says every story has to be
like this or every character has to have
a certain mark film doesn't have to be a
straightforward narrative it can be an
altogether new experience it can
challenge you in different ways you
didn't even know you could be challenged
in when the structure ingenuity and
clever building of a film is
their chances are you'll feel it and
labs half-assed and not much thought is
put into it chances are you won't feel
it so look at all the different
variations film can offer see what works
for you
see what doesn't and enjoy seeing it
transform from a series of sounds and
images to one of the most awesome
experiences ever even if you can't
explain why I'm gonna stop a critic I
remember it so you don't have to
you